i think jake is the perfect candidate
for us to recreate with ai
dude
jake is not aware that this exists right
now frankly once we show that what we've
done to him uh he'll give us consent
[Music]
previously on corridor crew
what is this it's freaking nico i've
been really impressed with nico's
ability to harness the power of deep
fakes to recreate someone's likeness
whether it's pre-rendered or recently as
we've seen in real time however
there is a key thing missing
from those recreations and that's the
voice so i'm going to figure out the
other half i'm going to figure out how
to make some great ai voices i'm not
going to get too deep into
like the code and processing right now
because there's already a lot of
services out there we've messed with
replica studios my family was butchered
by hellspawn another company called
resemble.ai
how can you call this a world now
there's lots of great features within
these programs however the actual voices
they're a little bit lacking i wonder
what sound you'll make when you hit the
ground a lot of these voices kind of
sound robotic each time i've
experimented with them it kind of sounds
like late 90s text-to-speech hello i am
macintosh
it sure is great to get out of that bag
so that's where i got in deeper there's
a company called dscript that purchased
the algorithm called lyrebird and
they've integrated it into their
transcribing software and it sounds so
good hey ren hey peter i hope you're
impressed with my super cool robot voice
in the future i will only type my words
and this robot will tell them to you
not bad that was crazy not bad dude it's
not bad that's the quality of like a
proper voice set and like proper
training on a proper ai voice model when
you say proper what does that mean to
record the voice data set i basically
just recorded myself for about 15
minutes i read a dnd book so it's like
you did all this training and you gave
that training data to them for them to
synthesize your voice
but now that that's that's something
that they now just hack they have it but
i don't think they're allowed to use it
aloud you know how like sometimes you
click i agree to your terms of service i
consent to this for this service they
make you literally speak into a
microphone as a recording saying i'm
consenting and i'm aware that i'm
providing my voice to this service and
once it's uploaded it can be
replicated like i have i had to
literally say that into a microphone and
that was my signature dude uh you got to
do some tongue twisters something that
you would be challenged to actually say
but the computer can say because it's a
computer
betty botter bought some butter but she
said the butter's bitter if i put it in
my batter it will make my batter bitter
but a bit of better butter will make my
batter better so tua's better betty
botter bought a bit of better butter
that was kind of nice
all right dude that's enough
that's nuts
guys
i
don't know how to express myself very
well so i had an ai express myself for
me anyways here's the song i dedicate
the song to you i love peter and ren
they're my favorite friends i hope we'll
always be together until the end peter
is so smart and ren is so sweet i can't
imagine my life without them by my side
they make me laugh and they make me
smile i'm so grateful they're in my life
i love peter and ren they're my favorite
friends i hope we'll always be together
until the end
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow that was romantic
i could literally do this forever
because the computer would just keep
doing it
so i've been doing some thinking here
fun fact there has never been more
people working at corridors studio than
at any other point in time well that
adds a lot of pressure for jake because
he is in charge of managing everyone's
schedules and workloads studio meetings
presentations now oh on top of it he
handles almost all the brand
integrations for every video today's
sponsor today's sponsor of today's
sponsor today's sponsor
jake has more pressure on his plate than
ever these days i think he's the perfect
candidate for us to
recreate with ai in order to alleviate
some of that workload i know he's going
to love this because the ai can automate
a lot of the tasks that require his
vocal presence however jake is fearful
of new technology and ai do you think an
ai will be a government body at some
point god i hope not jake lives in a
small compound in texas
and to him his rights his privacy those
those are very important to him and so i
know that if i'm going to go to him and
say hey jake in order to do this i'm
going to need you to certify and consent
all this stuff and we're sending your
voice to another company and they might
own your voice and all that he's not
going to want to sign up for that
we have a challenge here
the way you submit your voice set
through this service
is by speaking into a microphone a a
consent form it takes
that recorded sentence pairs it up with
your data set and makes sure that this
data set and the person agreeing and
consenting to everything are the same
person
so i can't make a fake
jake voice unless he consents to doing
it something i know
he won't agree to
if you're a filmmaker sometimes you know
that you're gonna have to film somewhere
you're not supposed to be or do
something you know you wanna get the
shot and so there's a little phrase that
it's easier to ask for forgiveness than
it is to get permission
unfortunately in this case we absolutely
need his consent to do it and so we're
going to take the hard path this time by
manufacturing
his consent the funny thing about this
is that t-script is supposed to be a
podcast transcription service where you
upload your podcast and it breaks down
all the words i'm using the same
software that i would be using to
recreate his voice to you know mash
these words together i can literally
just type it in here i can say currently
does he say currently ever oh
our world currently oh boom there we go
that's one word down you know
do we have a speech
oh yeah to do a speech oh we got speech
you need his name
oh yeah jake
of course me jake watson yes
if you have a podcast where you have
hours and hours and hours and hours of
your voice recorded out there
are you at risk for having someone make
an ai version of you yes is this immoral
yeah
i mean yes absolute this is totally
immoral but the thing is is that
thankfully i know that jake
once he sees the final product he'll
feel like he would have agreed
three hours later wren do you remember
how i mentioned that
i had to
speak consent
yeah yeah so i've laboriously gone
through
and recreated
his
consent form oh my oh this is
this is dirty this is dirty all right
here we go
it's going to be funny i hereby verify
that i jake watson i am currently
speaking and that i'd like to script to
create an overdub version of my voice i
understand that this overdub voice can
be used to create a speech that sounds
like my voice
oh my god dude
some words i just can't find
but i've kind of like mashed a few words
together and i i think i
i think it's gonna work so i'm going to
submit this and see if i can get it to
train the data set of all our podcast
footage to create
an aig voice
oh man jake of all people wouldn't be
happy about this but at the same time
he will like the results
i think maybe this is like breaking into
a facility and like knocking someone out
and then holding their hand up to the
scanner oh my god this is exactly that
i feel like i just witnessed a crime
technically you may have
oh no dude come back tomorrow let's see
if it works
okay well sam is in the studio working
on this voice ai mystery project i
wanted to talk to you guys about today's
sponsor story blocks storyblocks is your
one-stop shop for all your stock asset
needs storybox offers high quality 4k
b-roll
audio images motion graphics after
effects templates and more storyblocks
has a virtually unlimited library which
means that anytime you come back to the
site there's going to be something new
for you it offers multiple plans
including their unlimited all-access
plan the unlimited all-access plan
offers you royalty-free downloads as
much as you want for whatever you want
you can use it in commercial projects
personal projects or whatever else you
need we've been using storyblocks for
years now they are truly our one-stop
shop for all of our stock asset needs
anytime we need video images or audio
assets we just go on and grab it so if
you guys are serious about being a
creator or maybe you're a professional
creator already or you want to get more
tools in your creative toolkit so you
can create videos better faster and with
higher quality consider storybox huge
thanks to storyblocks for sponsoring the
channel and guys if you are interested
in getting started for yourself click
the link in the description below or
head on over to storyblocks.com
corridor crew
again that's storybox.com
corridor crew now back to my handsome
friend sam and the really cool project
he is working on that i know nothing
about
jake sent me voicemail
liar good morning everyone i've got a
big announcement today i've decided to
fly to ukraine to support the defense of
their capital city kiev you might not
see me in videos for a while until i get
back this ai voice will cover for me in
the meantime say hello you little rascal
peter piper picked a pack of pickled
peppers a pack of pickled peppers peter
piper picked if peter piper picked a
peck of pickled peppers where's the pack
of pickled peppers peter piper picked
just wait just be clear jake doesn't
know that this exists jake
is
not aware
that this exists right now and you're
not supposed to make ai models people's
voices you're not supposed to do it yet
we've seen so many
so many things like this like oh we took
mark hamill you know you scoured the
internet you found tons of images of
people's faces did all that stuff did
you get their permission to do it no no
no public personalities they're their
likeness the sound of their voice it's
out there in the world and it doesn't
take much to go out there and capture it
you know so it's so anyways we have jake
say whatever we want him to say
which frankly once we show that what
we've done to him uh he'll give us
consent but the best way to convince
jake is if he can see the effect that
this voice has on other people this
voice
lends itself to like him just espousing
wisdom
with inspirational quotes like this the
sun the source of all our power what
would we do without it there is also a
smaller
tidy sun inside each and every one of us
making a jake psa that's supposed to be
like all right here's like an update on
like my thoughts about work and studio
protocols i think that would go over
really well if you can see the effect
this ai voice in his likeness has on the
team
he'll be sold
so we have finally figured out the best
use for jake's ai voice and that's going
to be an inspirational team building
presentation
so in the same theme of taking work off
of jake's plate we've created a script
using gpt-3 all i'm going to do is give
it a few key facts about jake what he's
from texas i know he's getting into bow
hunting but i'm going to let it kind of
do the rest and fill in the gaps i think
this is going to work out really well
because all he has to do is sit back
relax
and
watch as the effect of this ai voice uh
changes everyone's mood it's going to
inspire them it's going to motivate them
you know it's a team building exercise
it's going to bring everyone together
and if you can see that look on their
faces we will surely get his post
consent to do this whole video i mean
just you watching this video right now
probably means this whole thing's going
to work
so we've scheduled a meeting for today
at 4 00 pm
we've told everyone it's a routine
scheduling studio protocol meeting
jake's going to hop on a video call with
us does you hear it yeah when you play
the video
you can hear the video
and once we make sure that his end's
working and he can hear everything
that's going on here
we are going to put him on you
and let his ai voice
do the talking
so with all the new people joining us we
wanted to do a little company culture
thing so actually
jake put together a video out in texas
for us what's that so he worked really
hard on it so if we could just watch it
you know i can see what you guys think
okay cool all right so yeah jake what
does the pilot jake once says yeah
lately i've been thinking a lot about
team building as the corridor team grows
it's important to be aware of what makes
a strong team and most importantly a
strong business
if you want to succeed in business you
have to be a team player and if you want
to be a team player you have to be from
texas
there's just something about texans that
makes them the perfect employees and
business partners maybe it's our fiery
attitude or our willingness to work hard
or our midwestern work ethic or the hot
air balloons we use to hunt goats with
our bow and arrows
why hunt goats you may ask because
they're delicious that's why but i
digress
whatever it is texans make great team
players and that's why businesses
succeed in texas but what else makes a
business succeed
the sun
the sun is the source of all our power
and businesses in texas thrive because
of our abundant sunshine so if you want
to start a business in texas you need
two things a team player and plenty of
sunshine
but there's a whole lot more in this big
old world than just texas what about
other parts of the country what does it
take to be a team player elsewhere in
order to be a team player in another
state you need to understand that
state's culture for example in
california you need to be aware of the
silicon valley culture
in new york you need to be aware of the
big apple culture
in texas you need to be aware of the
feared lone star culture a culture where
only the strongest and most ruthless
business people can survive
as we all know the human brain is a
powerful organ and it's especially
powerful when it comes to team building
the human brain is divided into two
hemispheres the left hemisphere and the
right hemisphere
the left hemisphere is responsible for
logical thinking while the right
hemisphere is responsible for everything
else that's why it's so important for
businesses to have a team of people who
can think logically and a team of people
who can think creatively in layman's
terms that means a team of texans and
non-texans
without that that business is doomed to
fail just like the dinosaurs who died
from a lack of sunlight
[Laughter]
so if you want to be a team player you
have to be strong you have to be tough
you have to be from texas or you have to
be from a state with a strong culture
that's why i'm moving to california
he's moving back i'm excited to be a
part of the silicon valley culture i'm
excited to learn about the silicon
valley way of doing things and i'm
excited to be a part of a team that's
going to change the world
you might be asking me right now
how are you going to change the world
what new project is up your sleeve well
that project is still a secret but i can
tell you this it's going to involve a
lot of culture a lot of team building
and a lot of sunshine
so stick together grab your bows and
arrows and get ready to take on the
world because the corridor team is going
to change the world
one goat at a time
wow wow
wow
that's pretty great
yeah you guys questions or thoughts jake
you want to like elaborate on this at
all all right here's here's the real
deal
what
i had nothing to do with that but how
that was your voice that was ai voice
oh you did sound kind of down in the
dumps
jake
um
i did this without your permission
or with your knowledge yeah
and unfortunately because i'm using a
service that requires your
consent
oh i see what happened i transcribed
nine hours of our podcast to find the
exact words that you say
to trick the voice id into thinking
you're giving verbal consent
sam you you might you might be going to
name and likeness jail this is so
sketchy if we if i don't get your
consent we can't release this video
because i might get banned from this
service and who knows what else are you
dressing me on camera in front of all of
my co-workers for consent yeah i just
need your consent i know i don't know
what you're doing with this we're not
consenting to giving away your voice i'm
still in control of it i don't know if i
believe that it's not like the company
gets to use your voice it's only to
prevent people from using other people's
voice for malicious purposes well
obviously that didn't work very well
dude yeah but
but obviously we've got to work around
here well let me just say this how about
this how about this why don't you
consent right now
and then i'll let you like take it back
if you don't feel comfortable later
right right yeah that always works out
well for people i i wouldn't i jake i
would never use your voice to harm you
i'm just saying here on camera i've not
used it for
anything else
other than the voices
that are in this video other than that i
have not messed with it
at all
the crime is committed
i you know i messed up but we can fix
this
there's a phrase in texas
and it's come and take it
but i took it
you didn't
i mean just listen to everyone they list
they listen to you your voice
meaning that this has potential in other
realms whether we're doing branded
segments other things but we can't
utilize it unless you know we get your
your consent i i really i really was
inspired by the speech the speech was
good yeah it's all about pain building
and all that stuff i'm feeling so
inspired i just can't use this
inspiration because it's just dirty
because it's non-consensual
pending pending his consent obviously
that removes the dirty feelings here who
would be inspired if he was to consent
to this
without question yeah never been foreign
i just need your consent for this one
video
you you have you have my consent for
this video
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you have it right there he has consented
to this video in the future we'll ask
for consent every time
at the beginning sam i'm going to be in
town next week
and i'd like to do some brand
integrations using this voice we can now
have a virtual jake where we hit a
content button we hit a brand
integration button and it prints brand
integrations all right
there we go
well that was a fun video the fact that
sam was able to navigate this technology
shows just how smart and handsome he is
if you guys like this video
and are looking for more fun videos with
ai consider checking out our website
corridordigital.com there you will find
a playlist with some wacky episodes from
our exclusive show
crew cuts thanks again for watching and
don't forget to subscribe this is sam
i mean jake signing off